que j'ai été invité sur le bateau pour
moi c'est pas sorcier safer lol vous le
garantis ben oui j'étais invité laubach
monsieur accurso avec john mbour pour
moi dans ma tête à moi dans ma petite
haie de grutier là puis de directeur
général dans le temps que je représente
l ensemble des travailleurs
c'était une belle réussite du genre je
dis j'en suis fier yapo de dano monique
rochus à l'extérieur de son ou de 2-2-2
ça coûtait 70 mais cinq mois ça m'a rien
coûté
est-ce cammas a coûté l'ensemble qu'elle
sert tout ça monsieur accurso ggg spas
hammams senti comme coupables ou
responsables de reposer ce château
j'en suis fier madame la présidente vous
parler d'eux